[Musique]
la natalité baisse aussi parce que
l'infertilité
progresse et je parle là d'une forme de
tabou du siècle mais les MEUR se change
on fait des enfants de plus en plus tard
l'infertilité masculine comme féminine a
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
et fait souffrir beaucoup de couples un
grand plan de lutte contre ce fléo sera
engagé pour permettre justement ce
réarmement
démographique notre France sera aussi
plus forte par la relance de sa
natalité nous étions jusqu'à récemment à
pays dont c'était la force sans doute la
singularité en Europe quand on se
comparait aux voisins et c'est moins
vrai depuis quelques années alors il y a
derrière cela des angoisses qui vont
avec la société peut-être des choix prix
jadic sur certains sujets financiers il
appartiendra au gouvernement de
poursuivre ce travail mais je voudrais
insister sur deux points pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses après
l'allongement du congé paternité je
crois profondément que la mise en place
d'un nouveau congé naissance sera un
élément utile dans une telle stratégie
congé de naissance qui viendra remplacer
le congé parental actuel d'abord il sera
mieux rémunéré il permettra aux deux
parents d'être auprès de leur enfant
pendant 6 mois sil le souhaitent et
surtout il sera plus court que le congé
parental actuel qui peut parfois aller
jusqu'à 3 ans et qui éloigne beaucoup de
femmes du marché du travail mais qui
aussi cré beaucoup d'angoiss parce qu'il
est extrêmement peu et mal rémunéré et
donc cré des situations parfois
impossibles
l'école primaire avec laquelle vous avez
commencé c'est là où on apprend à
compter à écrire à lire aussi à se
comporter c'est là o on apprend des
valeurs je suis totalement favorable à
ce qu'on apprenne la Marseillaise au
primaire totalement c'est même
indispensable parce c'est ce qui nous
unit c'est le fruit de notre histoire à
ce qu'il y ait donc l'heure sanctuirisée
si je peux dire de de la 5e
d'instruction civique avec un programme
qui est redéfin et qui permet de bien
mieux connaître à la fois l'histoire
tion rép
detion parce que c'est ce qui nous
unit qui n Perm d'êtreensemble en
société qui fait que je l'avais dit je
me souviens très bien la fin du grand
débat ce qui spare qui différene plutôt
une nation d'une société une société son
des individ li qui Coop qui s'organ et
nous société est plus que ça on a un
supplément on a une langue une histoire
des choses intemporelles qui nous lient
et un mystérieux projet commun qui fait
que face à l'adversité on se rassemble
pour affronter les événements c'est ça
une nation c'est a quelque chose de
spirituel qui nous dépasse et ça
s'apprend à travers cette histoire et
ces choses aussi symbolique et il faut
retrouver aussi le sens du symbolique et
c'est pour ça que la Marseillaise en
fait partie j'y suis
favorable et parce que la France est
aussi une histoire un patrimoine qui se
transmet et qui unit l'histoire de l'art
retrouvera sa place à la rentrée
prochaine au collège et au
lycée la tenue unique qui a donné lieu à
tant de débats ces derniers mois dans
notre pays et qui efface leses
inégalités entre les famille en même
temps qu'elle crée les conditions du
respect sera expérimenté dès cette année
dans une centaine
d'établissements tous
volontaires cette expérimentation sera
évaluée
méthodiquement et sur la base des
résultats s'ils sont concluants nous la
généraliserons en
[Musique]
2026 je demande donc au gouvernement de
sortir si je puis dire des codes et des
cases d'envisager des solutions plus
radicales pour mettre fin à ce qui
alimente ce sentiment de déclassement
solution radical pour mettre fin au
scandales des déserts médicaux en
simplifiant les règles venues d'en haut
en permettant d'adapter ses règles au
terrain pour permettre des coordinations
plus simples en dégageant du temps au
médecin pour mieux travailler entre
médecine de ville et hôpital avec aussi
ce qu'on appelle les professions
paramédicales sera au cœur du mandat de
la ministre afin que chaque médecin mais
aussi par puisse voir plusir de patient
mais aussi en assumant sur le terrain de
régulariser nombre de médecins étrangers
qui tiennent parfois à bout de bras nos
services de soins et que nous sont dans
une précarité administrative qui est
complètement inefficace
oui le service national universel fait
partie de la réform c'est pourquoi
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans les
prochaines semaines mais nous irons vers
la généralisation du service national
universel en
seconde il est cohérent avec ce que je
viens de vous
décrire vous avez d'abord raison de
rappeler
la France a perdu 41 de ses enfants dans
les attaques terroristes du 7 octobre
dernier ce qui fait ces
attaqu l'acte terroriste plus meurtrier
DEP
Nice le 7 février prochain
au monument pour les victimes du
terrorisme jardin desal je rendrai
hommage à ces victimes au côté de leurs
proches leur famille de tous ceux qui
voudront nous y rejoindre
ce sera 4 mois jour pour jour après
l'attaque
terroriste nous avons libéré quatreages
nous avons encore trois otages qui sont
détenus et nous nous battons pied à
pied avec les autorité israélienne avec
le Qatar qui a un rôle décisif en la
matière
avec aussi plusieurs autres collègues
pour les libérer je ne veux ici faire
aucune annonce parce que ces matières
sont toujours délicates et je pense
aussi aux familles
mais nous nous battons nous ne lâcherons
rien et j'espère que les prochains jours
prochaines semaines nous
permettront d'obtenir leur libération en
tout cas nous voulons tous les ramener
chez
nous et puis dès 2025 ça tout je vous
dis c'est sur 2024 et il y aura des
mesures de court terme que le premier
ministre aura à amcer donc sur la
rémunération du travail il y aura un
travail avec les branches qui continuent
de payer sous le SMIC pour qu'elle
réembauche davantage et qu'elles
attirent plus de travailleurs qu'elles
améliorent les conditions de travail et
qu'ell permettent d'avoir des dynamiques
salariales retrouvé et ça ça vaut pour
les métiers de la restauration les
métiers du soin beaucoup de métiers
d'ailleurs manuels est souvent difficile
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
ilue à avoir du mal à recrué et on aura
entre autres dans notre trajectoire
financière 2 milliards de baisse d'impôt
sur nos compatriotes qui sont dans ces
catégorie en 2025 et le gouvernement
reviendra sur le détail de la
mesure
[Musique]
l'ordre en luttant contre la drogue qui
ces dernières années se déploie pas
simplement dans les grandes villes mais
dans des villes moyennes qui la
connaissent moins parfois même dans des
villages grâce à la multiplication des
opérations PL net frappant les
narcotrafiquants qui se conduiront en
toutes les catégories de ville et nous
allons accroître le rythme à partir de
la semaine prochaine 10 opérations de ce
type seront conduites chaque
semaine
une histoire des devoirs des droits une
langue un
imaginaire le sens profond du respect et
de l'engagement et cela dès l'enfance en
renforçant le soutien et l'exigence
vis-à-vis des parents en reprenant aussi
le contrôle de nos écrans qui trop
souvent enferme là où il devrait libérer
sur la base de recommandations que font
les expert que j'ai réuni la semaine
dernière nous déterminerons le bon usage
des écrans pour nos enfants dans les
familles à la maison comme en classe
parce qu'il en va de l'avenir de nos
sociétés et de nos
démocraties